>>Male #1: Uh. Hello and welcome. And before
we get started, please remember to turn off
all pagers, cell phones, blackberries, smart
phones, android devices, and legacy Apple
products.
[Laughing]
>>Male #1: Bike Snob's a blogger/cyclists,
racer/commuter, as satirist/cultural observer,
and an online researcher finding the silliest
posters on Craig's list and slashing their
proverbial tires. His new book
helps us realize just how ludicrous we can
all be about cycling and just how ludicrously
cool cycling can be. From the history of old
timey cycling in his hometown of New York,
to poking fun of all the
various characters that perch themselves atop
bicycles, to straight out tips on how to ride
and how to thrive, the book is a homage to
the sport Bike Snob obviously loves. Since
we're here at at Google, I thought we take
a quick look at US Web search trends for the
term "bike snob" in 2010. While still not
as popular as terms like Lance Armstrong,
fixed gear, or even Lone Wolf...
[audience roaring laughter]
>>Male #1: ..."Bike Snob" does produce more
queries, uh, then Tour of California winner,
Michael Rogers; runner up, Leipheimer; or
even Nashbar coupons. This spring, web-search
traffic doubled when "Bike Snob" revealed
his true identity, Eben Weiss. Handily surpassing
queries for local cyclist/entrepreneur and
champion of cycling clothing as business casual,
Sergey Brin.
[audience laughing]
>>Male #1: Mr. Weiss is here today to talk
about his new book "Bike Snob." Following
the talk there will be a Q&A session. Please
remember to use the microphone when you're
asking questions for the benefit of the remote
video audiences, and this is being recorded
on YouTube. Our local book retailer Books
Inc., I believe has still got some books to
sell back there, and Mr. Weiss will be sticking
around to sign them. So please, join me in
welcoming Eben Weiss a.k.a. Bike Snob.
[audience applause]
>>Eben Weiss: Hi. Thank you very much for
ah, for coming. It's great to be here at at
Yahoo...
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: Um. Is this Yahoo or is that later?
Google, even better. It's great to be here
at Google, thank you very much. Um. Google
in a lot of ways in many, many ways made what
I'm doing possible now
which is ah, you know, riding this blog every
day, which is a great pleasure in my life,
uh, people seem to enjoy it. It's made it
possible me to to write a book and have it
published. It sent me on a tour
uh, all over the country or at least the cool,
trendy parts of the country. They don't send
me to the regular parts. They're sending me
on like the "Burrito Belt." Kind of the hipster
belt. But it's absolutely great and I-I-I-
seriously thank you for that. Having said
that, um, I've-I've dreamed of this moment
for some time because, um, while I-I do use
and I publish my blog using Blogger, um, and
uh, well April of 2009 you actually featured
me as a Blog of Note which was flattering,
which was nice for me. Uh. Right between Inside
the Loop and Moments of Perfect Clarity, I
don't know what those blogs are. I don't know
if any of them have been here, but here I
am. Um. And it was a nice moment, but then
a month later, I was-I should add that I was
I was monetizing with your Ad
Sense. Uh, but a month later I got this on
my Gmail, another fine Google product, that,
uh, what does it say? That you needed to terminate
my Ad Sense, because I'm-I'm-to protect the
interests of both our advertisers and our
other Ad Sense publishers. So I-I guess I
don't know why this was, and then I appealed
it. And this appeal was denied. So I-I I'm
kind of, I don't mean this to be, I'm-I nobody's
laughing. It's kind of funny. But I was kind
of reeling at the time, and I was wanting
to talk to people. I actually, I used to work
around the corner from, ah, 111 8th Ave in
New York which is where your New York brethren
and sisteren or [laughing]
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: They wouldn't let me in I tried to
kind of barnstorm, I tried to do the Michael
Moore thing, and they weren't having it. You've
got good security, you guys. You should feel
safe at work, but ah, they wouldn't let me
in. So I've been wondering all this time what
happened? I can't figure it out. I don't have
Ad Sense. Sometimes you invite me to do other
programs, I'm like well, that sounds
lovely I would like to do this program, but
you need an Ad Sense program to do it or membership
or whatever you call it. And I can't I've
been sort of locked out. Yet here I am talking
to you. And it's in interesting kind of thing
there and the only thing I can think of, I'm
sure there's a simple explanation that I did
wrong was like two days before you terminated
it, I did post this picture.
[Picture out of frame, cannot see]
[audience laughing loudly]
Weiss: But like first of all it was very much
in context, and it was making a really sophisticated
point about our culture and the about media
and all that stuff. And second of all, as
you can see, it's
censored. When I-I when I put anything racy
on the blog I make sure to sepia tone it,
because you know anything like, like from
the Victorian era like, even if they're naked,
that's not offensive.
Because after a certain point the statute
of limitations on nudity ends, you know. It's
fine. So I do that and then just for good
measure, Larry King-I always put Larry King
over anything. So there was
that. I don't know if this was a picture that
kind of made me a Google pariah...
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: And caused you to lock me out. But
I don't know, its food for thought for you
guys. I would love to kind of smooth this
over may be perhaps monetize you-monetize
with you again in the
future.
[audience laughing]
Weiss: Uh, you know, I think we can make this
work ethic we can salvage this I think working
together we can do this I'm just putting it
out there. So, okay but ah, you know and I
feel like I started off
on the wrong foot with you guys now and it's
awkward, but you know, let's let bygones be
bygones. Just gimme my account back. The money
that was in it, there was money in it, yo-
money there's
like, there was like hundreds of dollars in
there. Maybe one and a half hundred.
[audience laughing]
Weiss: So. Okay anyway. So having done that,
having gotten that, cleared the air. Uh, this
is the slide show proper. And what I've done
with the slideshow is, if you're familiar
with my blog and you're
not just here 'cause you're cutting out of
work, umm, my blog I make fun of a lot of
people on the blog. You know, I poke fun at
everybody, and I do that not to offend anybody.
I'm making fun of myself as
much as anybody else but I do it so we all
can laugh. But with the blog anonymously for
a long time and that's unfair you know it
doesn't let people get you back. So what I
wanted to do with the
slide show is give people the opportunity
to you know lay myself bare and let you laugh
at me as I've laughed at all of you. So that's
the slideshow, and I should add that my tour
and all of this is
brought to you by a company called Knog. Knog
is a manufacturer of cycling accessories and
lights among those lights are what are called
the Hipster Cysts. I don't know if anybody,
I call them
Hipster Cysts. They are called Knog frogs;
they're little lights you put on your bike.
That's my, I've put many Knogs on a bike there
so you can see what they are. So I want to
thank Knog for making this
possible. This is Michael Elliott from Knog
eating a chicken leg. That's-that's the inventor
of the Knog Hipster Cyst. So there you go.
Ah, okay.
So this is me, early on, this is my first
real bicycle. Non-big wheel, non-tricycle,
non-whatever. With the training wheels, uh
this is uh from the 1970s and that's how people
dressed in the 1970s.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: Uhhh, and I had the streamers and
the whole thing. Then I got a little older
and I got my first BMX bike which was this
Schwinn Scrambler which came with Skyway tough
wheel two-mag
wheels which were really cool wheels at the
time. And that kind of got me into loving
BMX. This is still the 70s. Ah, this is Bayswater,
Far Rockaway in ah New York. If anybody knows
it. Um, that
that's where I lived at the time. And again,
I should say that these clothes are very trendy
now. This was how people dressed in the 70s
just normally. This is the clothing that was
available to us at
the time. Like the ringer tee. I think it
was the Nashville T-shirt I was wearing. You
would just wear things like that. It wasn't
a statement. It wasn't a whole thing. Now
that shirt in that size, an adult
would wear and pay like $200 for it.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: its not-It wasn't like that. It was
a simpler time. All right. Next stage in my
evolution as a as a cyclist. Then I stepped
up to the uh, the Haro uh-uh bike, the Haro
BMX. I don't know if
anybody was into BMX back in the day as they
say. But Haros were pretty nice bikes, and
uh that's my brother Holden it down in the
background in the soccer jersey. Between the-you
didn't step to
us look at us you know and ah-uh, the socks,
it was normal to wear socks at knee-high height
like that. Regular thing to do. It was how
people wore their socks. They didn't, they
hadn't invented short
stocks yet. LeTigre, LeTigre tennis shirt.
Again very ironically trendy. I think there's
a band called LeTigre, no? Yes, in Williamsburg
or something? Back then, it was only a shirt
and it was just what you
wore. And ah valve, ah dice, valve-caps, that
was my first customization. I had the uh the
O.D.Y. White-mushroom grips, and the ah doughnuts,
which protected sort of the inside of your
hand. Very
important accessory uh, uh, still hadn't taken
off the reflectors though. It's a little embarrassing.
[audience laughing]
Weiss: Okay, so then you get a little older,
you know, your body chemistry changes, and
I entered into kind of a sullen phase in my
life. And during this sullen phase, this is
how I looked, and I would
skulk around in doorways as you do, just kind
ah. Well, you did, you just kind of dress
a certain way, one at a certain face and you'd
find a cool doorway and you can lean in it,
and you'd be
you'd be kind of sullen. And that's a good
look for doing that. This look however, is
not a good look at the beach where it goes
horribly, horribly awry. Where the salt air
just enters the hair and it
just goes BAM! And it's-it's you know, not
a good look for the beach. Um.
Then, then I started racing and all of that
stuff. So this is what I look like when I
was a lowly Cat 5 just starting to race, hadn't
discovered the bib shorts yet. I was still
wearing the half shorts.
Ahhh, I was way too into having a Cannondale.
A Cannondale jersey and water bottle and bike.
But that's the beginning, that's when I started
racing. It's before I kind of you know, before
you get
into team, and you have a kit and the whole
thing. And you think you're cool. But pasty
white legs, just been shaved, umm, and then
that my brother's 200 SX in the background
there. That's for sale
if anybody's interested.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: I got that out of the parking lot,
uh, I'll take $200 for it. Uh, that that car
is on the scrap heap now. I'm sure that was
a while ago. Ahh, right that's my newborn
son. How did that get in there?
I don't know? He's three weeks old.
[audience clapping]
>>Weiss: Thank you. To Elliott... that's just
a gratuitous baby insertion shot. Thank you
for that.
Okay now I'd like to take a little detour...ummm
cycling in New York City. I write a lot about
cycling in New York City. Um, I don't know
how many of you have cycled in New York City.
I don't know where most of you guys live.
I mean I-I-I love
coming out here and riding even in the city
even in San Francisco I think it's very pleasant
place to ride. It's pretty chill. Um, ah.
New York is getting better and better but
it's pretty bad.
So this um, I wrote an article in Outside
magazine a while ago about Portland. And in
it, I mentioned, this was last fall, I mentioned
just before leaving for Portland I got hit
by a car, uh, from behind. I
was just riding along, JRA, as they say in
the bike shops, and somebody just kind of
hit me from behind. And this is the woman
who hit me from behind and that's her maroon
Buick and this is the
picture I took as I just after I collected
myself off the pavement bloodied and limping
and I was like a limping towards her like
a like a zombie. You know, all scraped up
and she stood there just kind of
with her hands behind her back as you can
see just kind of curiously looking at this
bloodied, Lycra-clad guy kind of just limping
towards her, um, and ah that's her. And her
name and address are as
follows.
[audience roaring laughter]
>>Weiss: So if you have anything that you'd
like to say, if you want to send her pizzas,
you get bored on Friday night, if you have
any decaying organic matter you're not going
to composts, although
I'm sure all of you composts everything, but
anything smelly or horrific you want to send
her, please do. I couldn't find her number,
but I did I did use your your popular search
engine, um, to try to
learn more about her. And it turns out that
she shares a name with a Playmate of some
note.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: So, I didn't get hit by that Crystal
Harris; I got hit by this Crystal Harris.
So after she hit me and after I dragged myself
over to her and she kind of- oh and I said,
"What happened? What did
you do there?" She just said, she said, "I
thought I could get around you." And that
was it. She thought she could get around me,
but she couldn't. And so there I was kind
of propped up against the
wall of a car wash waiting for the police
to come. And she was just highlighting something.
She was just sitting there highlighting. I
don't know what it was. Umm, so that's it.
So that was my view for
like a half hour before the cops came, and
lawyers would stop and try to solicit my business.
>>Audience member: Oh my god!
>>Weiss: cat some guy in a really slick suit
stopped his Escalade and was like a you know,
"You may need a lawyer for this." I was like,
just keep keep rolling, keep going. I could've
been looking at that
Crystal Harris for a half hour while I was
bleeding, but I was looking at this Crystal
Harris for a half hour while bleeding. So
that's just another day of cycling, in New
York City.
So back to the blog, I used to write the blog
anonymously. This is an actual, this is how
I worked; I worked in the dark I was that
scared. Then I revealed myself, lights on
there I was laid bare. I
worked in the bathroom by the way. Umm. And
not everybody liked it when I when I became
unanonymous or whatever you call it. Like
I like, you know how the Internet is people
like the kind of flame
you and complain and say your sellout and
a shark jumper and all that kind of stuff.
So like typical chatter and this is Twitter
so you have to read from the bottom. So I'd
say this like, "Man this Bike
Snob guy is one self-promoting crazy Jew every
effing post more effing blah."
Then he could bet he reworked it. Then he's
like, "Man this Bike Snob guy is one self-promoting
mother-effer every effing post more effing
blah." Then he went from Jew to mother-effer
for some
reason. Then he recanted the whole thing right
there at the end. That came out really wrong.
I'm sorry about that.
[audience laughing loudly]
>>Weiss: I don't know, I don't know. But you
know it hasn't all been ah, ah insults and
complaints. I've had some, I've-I've-I've
had some, I'm very happy that people have
enjoyed the book and the blog
and have been very supportive. Uh, even people
in the world of cycling. Even, and you know
even ah former, even Tour de France Winners
have, have come out and supported me. One
in particular
really famous, Tour de France winner. I'm
sure all you know who he is...
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: Good to have him in my corner. You
want a guy like Floyd in your corner. That's
him that's Photoshop by the way, that's not
real. That was a reader that sent me that.
And by the way, Floyd,
and I don't know how many of you saw-caught
him at his Google appearance, but he was here.
Did anyone see Floyd when he was here? Yep,
Floyd was here. So you know, that's kind of,
I watched
that the other day as was like, that's kind
of funny. He really kind of laid it on there.
>>Male from Audience: If you want a copy of
his book, I think I have one.
>>Weiss: Yes please, I would love one. Uh,
there you go. That's it that's my presentation
thank you. Uh, ah golf claps all around. Okay,
thanks. Now um, ah, ah, if anyone has the
questions I would be
happy to answer them, and if anybody just
kind of wants to insult me, I'd be happy to
stand here and take it. Or anything in between.
Questions? Concerns? Yes.
>>Male #2: You're going to have to repeat
the question for me. Did you find it stressful
at all keeping yourself anonymous? Were you
afraid of getting found out, and how did that
impact you?
>>Weiss: ah, was I afraid of like repercussions
when I became an anonymous or...
>>Male #2: When you were anonymous comment
how paranoid were you about being anonymous?
>>Weiss: oh, I eh I wasn't really. How paranoid
was I about this staying anonymous when I
was anonymous? I don't know I was pretty,
I was pretty tight about it like I never really
told people only told
people close to me. Um, I just wanted to stay
anonymous, and um, but after a while it felt
kind of like ah, it felt gimmicky. And people
were finding out anyway, and then, then you
just kind of you
know, it would be embarrassing to be like
still anonymous now and thinking people think
you're anonymous and they see you. It's like
being naked and thinking nobody sees you.
So, so, I dispensed with
it. Uh, any anything else? Yes, in the spinney-beanie
hat.
>>Male #3: [inaudible]
>>Weiss: Oh, can you, I'm sorry, can you can
you speak into the microphone so that this
could be recorded for eternity in the annals
of YouTube another fine Google product.
>>Male #3: Do you own…
[sound of hand tapping on microphone]
any bikes that can do bar spins?
>>Weiss: Ah, do I own any bar-spinnable bikes?
No, I don't think any of my bikes are bar-spinnable.
Uh, if bar spins aren't familiar that's where
you kind of ride, you do like a wheelie and
you spin your
handle bars around. For some reason the youth
of America is just absolutely thrilled by
this. Ah, no, because they all have cables,
they all have brake cables on them so they
can't spin around. No, no
I'm thinking of getting one though. Anything
else? Questions? I'm taking, taking this as
a sign that my presentation was very thorough.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: No questions? Floyd's stories from
when he was here? No que-
>>Male #4: Are you doping?
>>Weiss: Am I doping?
[laughing]
Don't I,I-I-I, Don't I seem like I'm doping?
I'm on Adderall and cough medicine right now,
I don't know what's happening. Ahhh. Yes.
>>Male #5: Can you tell us what your favorite
kind of bike is?
>>Weiss: Favorite kind of bike. Uhhhh. It
depends on what I'm doing, I just like um,
it depends on what I'm doing. My favorite
kind of riding is ah, well one of the things,
I should say the reason I wrote the book,
uh and the book, uh, is a little different
from the blog and that I try to make it as
funny as the blog, uh but I also try to make
it a little more ah endearing maybe is the
right word. The kind of thing that sort of
explains why I love cycling instead of just
making fun of it, why I love this. Why I think
cycling's a great thing, and why it's brought
me a lot of a lot of joy and happiness and
all of that stuff and, and
that's because the thing that's great about
riding a bike is that you can have a lot of
fun doing it, you can do it purely recreationally,
you know you can race or you can do your long
rides on the
weekend but you can use it totally practically.
But you can enjoy that practical use you know
you can enjoy your commute. You can sort of
weave it into your day. There is not a lot
of things you can
do that with. You know, so that's what I like
about it. So my favorites kind of bike, it
really depends. I love I have just a beat
up city bike that I use to get around town,
and I love that bike. You know
I just love a bike that's completely useful
and absolutely not precious and that you can,
that just does its job. And ah um ah but you
know I love road bikes, mountain bikes, cycler-cross
bikes, ah all of it. Just not
recumbent those things scare me. Yes hi.
>>Male #6: I'm curious about your blog as
a blog. You mention you had written for Outside
before. Is that before the blog? And when
you started the blog did you have the plan
to sort of keep it up at
the level you have or did it kind of grow?
>>Weiss: Ahh, no all the writing like for
Outside and I write a column for Bicycling
Magazine and I do some other writing like
that and this book, all of that came out of
the blog. So, um, and when I started the blog
I had absolutely no kind of grand design or
plan or anything like that. I wasn't even
much of a blog reader. I just kind of, I've
always been a writer and I've always been
kind of in the publishing scene or
world or whatever you want to call it, but
I just I just started playing around with
blogger and started posting and just decided
to it every day, and I was really thrilled
and happy that people kept on.
So no, absolutely no plan or forethought really
or anything like that. Just really fortuitous.
Questions or are you trying to slip out unseen.
Ah, yes.
>>Male #7: So, so, how many bike do you own
and how many bikes is too many? Like general
guidance.
>>Weiss: Ahh, I own, I think I own six bikes.
So when you ride a lot and if you, I race
as well. I mean you know, you say you race
and some people think you're serious, good
rider and I'm not. When you
race you wind up having a lot of bikes for
different kinds of races. So I think I have
six, but it sort of fluctuates. you sell bikes
to get new ones. So, I think I have six. I
think too many bikes is just if you
have that bike you don't ever ride. You know
if you have that bike it's just kind of sitting
around there and not getting used you have
too many bikes. But you know if you have 20
bikes and you ride
them all the time it's fine. You could have
one you could have 50. Yes.
>>Male #8: Can you kind of describe how much
commitment it takes to keep bikesnob working?
Like, how many hours a day? Or how much time
is involves?
>>Weiss: How much commitment it takes? Um,
it definitely takes a lot of commitments because
when I started the blog I was working a full-time
job at a literary agency, and I
was dedicated. I published every day, every
weekday and I was very committed to that.
As soon as I realized I had an audience, I
was very, very, very, very grateful for that
and I was determined to
keep my audience, my readers whatever you
want to call them, something every day and,
and no matter what the costs. So it took a
lot of commitment because when you have a
full-time job and
you're writing a blog in the morning and sometimes
writing it on the company time or really most
of the time. You know, like your posting under
heavy fire. I get bosses yelling at me. I'm
going to get
this, if I get fired during the course of
posting this I'm fine with that. Because really
once I, once the blogs started going out with
committed 100%. So fire me, do whatever, I'm
going to do it. My
publisher could only send me to so many places.
My publisher and Knog. I'm a first-time author
of a book about cycling so it's not like.
I'm lucky and grateful that my publisher was
able to send me to
any cities. No, seriously and and LA, I would
love to go LA to visit, and I plan to one
of these days and actually you read more and
more about LA, and how it's how much cycling
stuff is going on
there, and um, it's seriously something I
want to go experience. But unfortunately,
they were not on the tour.
>>Male #9: So, actually have two questions.
Firstly, the best post you ever wrote was
the one where you described the little things
look for in people's bikes to see if they're
serious or not.
>>Weiss: Yeah.
>>Male #9: --Like whether their sticker is
over the tire lines on the valve stem and
that kind of stuff.
>>Weiss: Yeah.
>>Male #9: --One notable omission was you
didn't describe looking for the ferrules on
the end of cables which I was
surprised that you missed. I always look for
that. I wanted to see if there's any other
things that you thought of since then. And
then the second question what's your least
favorite and most favorite
maintenance task on a bike?
My favorite and least favorite... I'll start
with that one. My favorite and least favorite
maintenance task, I think my least favorite
maintenance task on a bike is like anything
involving the
drive train and cleaning there of or chain
removal and all of that especially because
I tend to neglect that stuff to begin with
so. If I have to touch my drive train, it's
like I was paddling around in
the Gulf. It's like I'm and covered in black.
It's not good so I hate that.
I really really enjoy, I'm not very good at
it, ah but I really like building wheels.
Like, I could build wheels all day long. Bad,
misshapen out- of-true wheels, but wheels.
It's really it's like it's like knitting.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: Yeah. In terms of other nitpicky,
stuff on bikes that I notice like I don't
know there's so many things. The ferrules,
sometimes you don't use the ferrules. I don't
want to get into a whole ferrules
thing here, but sometimes you don't use the
ferrules. Fig.
>Fig: Thank you for being here. At first,
I think I was introduced to your blog with
two posts which are incredible. First was
your bicycling editor's choice where you use
such colorful language as, "...
descends like a squirrel, a greased squirrel
in a luge and accelerates like a particle
in a particle accelerator, which itself is
itself a particle in a giant particle accelerator."
>>Weiss: Yeah.
>>Fig: Bicycling magazines should actually
get you to write their um bike reviews. Anyways,
um, are there any posts that you enjoyed particularly
writing? Some it seems like you're really
inspired and completely
on fire. Are there any that you remember just
loving like the "World's Greatest Madone".
Oh, my God, it was...
>>Weiss: Yeah.
>>Fig: I went and showed my bike shop friends
and oh, man they get huge kicks out of it.
>>Weiss: Thank you very much first of all,
it's hard it's hard to think of one, you know,
I mean obviously some are better than others.
And, and, that you know, they are just not
all going to be good,
but I-at least there's something everyday.
But, um, and that bicycling one is a favorite
of mine because I really had fun writing that
and that was definitely a moment and writing
the blog where I
know that post got forwarded around the lot
and I know it brought a new a lot of new readers
to the to the blog and so, so it was fun to
write and it was great to see people enjoy
it. And people from
Bicycling saw it and liked it, and I think
it was after that that Bicycling first, like
in the very early days of my blog they did
a little profile of me. I think that is how
I got on their radar.
Oh, another post that comes to mind is a post
I wrote about Michael Ball. The guy who was
the owner of Rock Racing which was kind of
like, they were like a wrestling team but
for cycling. They were
like lots. He also owns a jeans company. Those
kinds of jeans with lots of wrinkles and stuff.
Really expensive jeans. I wrote a post about
Michael, like from Michael Ball's perspective
where he
like drew a wheel on a napkin and how he was
going to make this wheel. Its describing blog
posts is not the most amusing thing.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: But that post I was very fond as
well.
>>Fig: I'll have to hunt that one down.
>>Weiss: Yeah.
>>Male #10: Two things: First of all, of an
LA native um, I'd like to warn you that most
people who see people on bikes look at them
funny and ask where's the engine?
>>Weiss: Right.
>>Male #10: Um, may not be the best, most
friendly city. Probably not nearly as bad
as New York, but um, and I am completely forgetting
the second thing that I would like to ask
you.
Laughing
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: With regard to the, oh did you did
you remember? Or I was going to...
>>Male #10: I'll go to the back of the line
and ask whenever everyone is done.
>>Weiss: Okay, with regard to the thing about
L.A. From where I'm sitting which is not in
L.A. I see more and more people and its younger
people obviously but a really like taking
pride in the fact that
they're are riding bikes and there's a real
emerging kind of commuting thing. Or at least
there appears to be in here from people in
LA all time say more and more people are riding
and it's exploding and I
have to come there. So now, you're from L.A.
and I'm not, but I don't know maybe the last
few years it's gotten better or not. What's
her name? Anne Hathaway hit that guy on his
fixed gear a few
months ago. Do you remember that? It was unfortunate.
[audience laughing]
>>Male #10: the other thing that I was going
to ask was you may have seen in the blue conveyances
around the Google campuses. Would you care
to the critique them?
>>Weiss: Ahh, no, I mean you know, I know
you have your whimsical colored bikes that
you kind of hop around and jump on and off.
It looks great. It makes sense. Yeah, everything
is very cutesy
colored around here. so it's like M&M land
is very nice, it's charming. It's wonderful.
It's cool that you got bikes around here.
You should use Penny-farthings though. They're
more sustainable too. They
don't use chains and lubricants.
>>Male #11: So for your personal bikes, what's
your most favorite thing to customize. Some
people might handlebars some people prefer
shifters, wheels what's the part of your bikes
that you get most
obsessed with.
>>Weiss: I don't customized bikes. I-I am
very very ah, ah, kind of minimalist in that
since when it comes to bikes. I really enjoy
putting them together and putting in doing
the work on them like I said I
liked building wheels, collecting all that
kind of stuff. I don't do anything on the
bikes just how to make them look a certain
way. I don't get really excited about the
way the bike looks particularly. You
know I want it to look, I don't want it to
have all those weird colors like a Google
bike or something. But I just like it to be
kind of no-nonsense but I enjoy bike the process
I enjoy like is the wheels.
It's fun to wrap art tape. You feel good when
you knew when you do a nice job, when everything
looks tidy. I'm tidy, except for the drive
train which is filthy.
>>Male #11: And so second question would be
one of the things, I like your posts, and
if I don't have a chance to read it, I always
go out and look at the images. Ah, could you
comment on maybe three
or four the most favorite images you've ever
posted.
>>Weiss: Most definitely the Lone Wolf image
is, a lot of people it has resonated with
a lot of people and again describing blog
posts is not the most entertaining thing ever.
I'll wish I had a slide of him,
but he's kind of a character in LA by the
way who rides around on a on a on a on a fared
mountain bike thing with like 18 bottles of
water kind of coming off the seat posts. He's
very is a compelling
character, the Lone Wolf. There's a something
called the world's greatest Madone. Which
is a Trek bicycle. It's like a full on race
bike with carbon wheels but the guy kind of
flap bars and a rack on it. And
turned it in- it's like $9,000 townie bike
so it's insane. So that by that was a great
picture. But those are two pictures that people
have sent me. That came from people. I another
one of the great
things about writing the blog is that you
hear from people all the time and people send
you great pictures like that. So, those of
the standout moments and of course the woman
with the turtle. That I
showed earlier. But that got me a little hot
water.
>>Female #1: so living in San Francisco, biker's
rights are obviously a huge issue and ends
by month your article in Outside magazine
I thought it was awesome. But along the stream
sort of wanted to
get your take on your travels what cities
you've seen that had some of the better improvements
or some of the better bike, more bikable improvements.
>>Weiss: Better, cycling experiences? Every
time I've come to this area to Northern California
I absolutely love it I really like this area
and um I'm arriving in San Francisco is a
real pleasure and riding up
over the bridge and around there it's great
ah. And going to Portland as well. Portland
was ah, just in terms of riding and you know
all the hype is about Portland being so bike
friendly but a lot of it's
legitimate and that it's very, very easy to
ride your bike there in the city for transportation.
Yet you can duck out in five minutes out of
downtown you're in Forest Park and, and on
unpaved roads
through the ferns or whatever kind of plants
they are. Portland's a great place to ride,
it's great. But you know New York's great
too. It's a lot better than people think.
>>Male #12: So about how much e-mail to you
give every day in response to blog.
>>Weiss: It's hard to quantify. I don't count
it exactly. It's, it's, it's I mean it's not
like stupendous, but it's more than I can
really take in. You know, unfortunately there's
a lot of stuff uh, I don't get to
read because it's a lot of e-mail lets them
I get some good e-mails with business proposals
that I'm always sure to respond to. The Nigerian
ones and all that. Those are always welcome
and have done
well for myself with those, but ah, yeah,
a decent amount.
>>Male #12: And second question in the book
you say when a when you're angry to melt cheese
with your eyes I was wondering what kind of
cheese are we talking about? Are we talking
about a cheddar or we talking about like a
wheel--
>>Weiss: now I could melt melt pecorino, I
could melt pecorino. I melted the whole wheel
of cheese when you guys canceled my Ad Sense.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: and I grated some cheese, too. Yes.
Hi.
>>Male #13: I was just curious was that your
first kid that we saw? And so have you, what
you think, what are your thoughts on kids
on bikes or riding with babies on bikes? What
kind of bikes would
you modify to attach the baby to?
>>Weiss: Oh yeah, a means to be a while before
he you know next, their necks don't work so
you can't even think about it. Although I
know somebody claims that he used to carry
his baby in his
messenger bag. But I'm not doing that so I
don't know. Uh this Surly, the company Surly
lent me one of their big dummy cargo bikes.
And if ah, I intend to give it back to them
until they make me. But
that would be a good baby bike when he's old
enough and can keep his head up. You know
that seat on the back there and do the whole
thing, yeah.
>>Male #14: You don't seem to be a real big
fan of charity cycling events, ah at least
that's what I've gathered from the blog, and
ah, I was hoping maybe you could just speak
to that a little bit. One of the
ah on the one hand you could say it brings
a lot of people into cycling and wouldn't
do it unless it was a friend or race down
to LA or something but you seem to have kind
of the opposite view.
>>Weiss: Oh no, I haven't no, big fan of charity
rides. If I make fun of charity rides on my
blog it's usually because you have the person
on the charity ride who thinks it's a race
and takes it really
seriously and is at the front. So that's when
I'm making fun of it. To people that come
to come at it who like you said, it brings
a lot of people to cycling it introduces us
to get to them. And then you have
people like that. And then you have the guy
who's got the full-on carbon bike and he's
got the kit on that he's got the bushy, hairy
legs and like he's gonna throw-down at the
charity ride. That's what I'm making
fun of you know. The guy who's not that hasn't-
you want to be competitive? Step it up. [laughing]
>>Male # 13: Ok, thanks.
>>Male #14: Speaking of hairy legs—
>>Weiss: Yeah.
>>Male #14: and I want to talk about that
for a minute. So is it, I have hairy legs.
Is there anything I can do to offset the discrimination
from that or am I only making it worse?
>>Weiss: You could shave your legs.
[audience laughing]
>>Weiss: No, I don't know. I just threw that
hairy-legged reference in there I think it's
weirder to shave your legs. I mean it's kind
of silly thing to do. No, where that hair
with pride.
>>Male #14: Do you think it looks worse to
have everything together except the legs?
Like maybe if you toned it down it may actually
look better?
>>Weiss: To tone what down? The rest of the
wardrobe?
>>Male #14: You have the rest of the kit and
the bike and you've got everything but you've
got the hairy legs. Is that better or is it
better to--
>>Weiss: I don't want to get too into the
hair that like if you have crazy wild, pelty
hair and then you wear a kit, sometimes it's
just you know. It's a jarring contrasts. You
know you get the kind of Lycra and then poof.
[audience laughter]
So then you might, you know, but you otherwise
a little hair is fine. You know, hair is hair.
Any other questions hair or not hair related...
going once... going twice... and what?
>>Audience member: [inaudible]
>>Weiss: [laughing] And that's it.
[applause]
>>Weiss: Ok.